All right, I'm ready
to have people come in.
Yesterday I put out
a text on my community
that I know a lot of you are part of
and I have people in the queue
with questions from that platform.
And now go live.
URL is in my (software
interferes with speech)
All right.
Good.
It's gonna show up.
- What's up, Gary.
- How are you?
- I'm doing well.
My question is, how are
you keeping your clients
calm and so motivated to
do business or lobbying
and partake everyone's
situation out there right now?
- I mean, just communication.
Just trying to remind people
that money isn't, and
they'll be all like.(mumbles)
It's all about really,
building a a lot of relationships.
If one is not valuing money
all the time,
then you have a much better chance of
actually getting them to be okay.
Like if I said to you like,
" Hey, you're not going to be--"
Hold on once again.
Instagram going,
the URL is in my profile right now.
If you want to watch the live.
You know, if you're in
a place where I'm like,
"Hey bro, if you're going to lose
" that beautiful tree painting behind you
"and you're not gonna
live in the same house"
and things of that nature.
All of a sudden if the person
isn't scared about that,
it gets a lot easier.
So I'm a big fan of worst case scenarios.
And so when people start freaking out
like some have, I'm like,
"What, what?"
"you lose something else?"
So I think it's a game
of worst case scenario.
And right now we have had some clients
that have had a let us go
'cause they just don't have the money.
We have a lot of uncertainty
going into these next 12 to 24 weeks.
Nobody knows how it's going to look like.
But to me, ultimately I go into a place
where I'm like, it'd be intermediate
or goes out of business,
then I'll start over.
Like I don't know how
to get scared by money.
I'll be honest with you.
That's really it.
Trying to get my employees,
my partners, my vendors, and my clients
to not be scared about money.
When they start freaking out,
a couple did this week.
If you need, ill probably get
you a job in another company.
You're just getting people okay with that
and letting them feel comfortable
(software interferes with speech)
- Awesome, thank you.
- How about for you?
What do you do and what's
going on on your end?
- I sell sunrooms,
skylights, conservatories,
of residential side and commercial side.
The residential side,
we're still going commercial side.
I sell to restaurants and hotels
and it's just completely stopped.
- And was that a big
percentage of the business?
- Fair amount, yeah, it's about 30%.
- Are you worried or how are you thinking?
- I am a little worried,
but at the same time I feel like
if I made it through 2008 I
can make it through anything.
- How many employees do you have?
- I'm self employed.
- That's good.
- Yeah.
- And what are your
biggest expenses, Mortgage?
- Yeah, got the rent, car payment.
But again, having gone through 2008,
I tied my belt.
Last time I was over leveraged
two houses in a condo
this time I'm good.
- I like that.
So it's just about like kind of like
quality of life.
I didn't call it quality of life,
I call it quality of family.
Like that's the only thing
that potentially gets tightened, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I mean, is your question
based on how you wanna
conversation with somebody,
your hotel and restaurant owners?
- Just everyone, like
people are listening,
to this 24 hour news cycle,l
nothing but negativity
and we get out there
and they're already bombarded
with all this trash in their head.
And I just wanna talk to you
and see how you're
keeping your clients going
and take it from there.
- It's funny, like I don't overly think
that the news cycle is trash
in the same way that I don't think
the people on social media that are like,
"This doesn't mean shit or trash"
Like its, the answer's
always in the middle right?
- Right.
- It'd be practical you know,
a lot of these things are real right now
and there's a lot of
practicality that is required
around something like this.
And what I mean by that is,
I think it's important for people
to ask more of these things
and that the market
(software interferes with speech)
is gonna be soft.
No matter how much of a
bailout the government creates,
you know there's going to be so many of us
in small businesses that are,
we're not going to get our
(software interferes with speech)
Their lives are gonna be completely
in a better place than they were.
(software interferes with speech)
Its going be a challenge.
And so I'm just gonna have people,
you said the experience of 2008,
the experience in 2001
for us that's old dogs,
that's gonna help.
I'm a little bit
concerned for people that,
(software interferes with speech)
and have never been through any of this
and helping them try to navigate it.
You are a young dog and
over leveraged, in a way.
You learned that lesson.
That's why you and I have
some growing up beards.
- Yeah.
Growing the beards are good for that show.
So it's just about over communicating,
keeping it in the middle.
And I think the answer
that I give you up front
is the answer.
If you don't overvalue
money, then it's good.
- That's what's up, thanks again.
- That's easy, and I'm like listen,
you don't have to have a car,
maybe you take public transportation.
Like you don't have to own a home,
maybe you rent an apartment.
Like people are not full
of loud intelligence.
(software interferes with speech)
- Nobody's owed anything
and if you didn't need money
and bought $13 cocktails
and went on $8,000
(software interferes with speech)
and you didn't put that in the bank
to help you through a rainy day,
the consequences are you losing things
and that's the way it
should be in a lot of ways.
- Yeah, and you've been warning everyone
about this for a minute.
- Not because I'm smart
and definitely not cause I
knew fucking Corona was coming,
but because that's just how life is.
Its cycles, right?
- Yeah.
- Its just good to save a little.
Anyway, I appreciate you bro,
talk to you soon.
- Thank you.
(software interferes with speech)
- See ya.
All right Dustin, I know
you're on the other side.
Thanks Adam.
- Thank you.
- Let this handsome man off, Dustin.
Get me into my next question.
All right, for everybody else.
Am I on right now, Dustin?
Like while you're making this--
(software interferes with speech)
let me go back on Instagram.
Make sure they know what's going on.
Hope everybody is super good.
Hope that made some sense to you
Arly, what's good?
- Hey, what's going on Gary,
good morning?
- Good morning, what's going on?
- Oh, not really much.
I'm sitting here getting
ready to start the day here
in a few minutes.
How are you doing today?
- I'm well, Where are you?
- Oh, just outside Buffalo in New York.
- Love it.
I'm well brother, thank you for being on.
What can I answer?
- No, thank you.
So my question is,
what's the best way you
found, if you have found,
on how to get clear what
you really want in life?
Like a mid all the noise
and the prettiest positions
and all that stuff.
Like how to listen to
what you really want.
- Who's carrying the most,
volume in your head besides you?
- Well, I moved home to
help take care of my parents
for like health reasons and
some financial stuff for them.
But I've gotten to the point where
I got that pretty well tied up.
And now it's where I can
start focusing on me more.
So a lot of it's been that.
- Okay, so first of all that's amazing.
Like I'm stuck, obviously
with my life's story
of going into my family
business to build it up for them
and kind of move on.
I just admire so much when
people have the strength
to go back home and help
parents, whether it's health
or financial and whatever other reasons.
So I really admired you for that bro.
- Thank you.
- I really do.
I think it's something you'll
never regret, you know?
- Yeah, I agree.
- No matter how pumped
you are going into it
or how fucking begrudging
you are going into it.
- yup, yup.
- Are you saying that
you've gotta restart now
and recalibrate and like remember
what the fuck you wanted
or if you were that,
during this time
some of the concepts and perceptions
they apparently have,
might've seeped in during the hotel.
- I'm fortunate that they were never,
they've never been like,
"Oh you should go do this
" 'cause you'll be successful."
Like that message very much resonates
that you always talk about
some of my friends I've seen,
but I've really been free to kind of
make up my own mind as far as that goes.
- What do you like?
- Go ahead.
- Give me more context.
- Yeah, I was going to
say basically what I got
out of school that's been kind of shit
started hitting the fan with them.
So I took a job where I
could work in remote sales
to be here and help them out.
And now that's kind of
where I have this freedom
to more focus on me and what I wanna do.
And I know I wanna go into
business for myself one day
but I'm having a hard time in figuring
out exactly in what and what exactly.
- Let's talk about you like Charlie.
What do you fuck with?
Sports, music, cooking, travel.
I think the people actually,
first book I wrote," Crush It".
- I laid it as sound, which is okay.
I think this internet
thing is about to be big
and I think actually in essence
what it basically said was, I
think you can be an influence.
Like, or vlogger or blogger or please make
(software interferes with speech)
the first business unit in hindsight,
like I think one of the reasons want to
getting cards is because I like it.
and I'm trying to take my own medicine,
which is like you'll always do better
in things that you like more.
- Yeah.
- so, like what do you like?
- Yeah, I mean I love,
like skiing, that's my
favorite thing to do.
I love skiing.
I played football through most of my life
so I love sports too,
but it kind of always came second.
I do love helping people.
Like it's really cool
when I can help someone
then it changes their life
whether it's some
business or what have you.
Like, with my parents--
(software interferes with speech)
- Immediately, I go into this
idea of like this business
that it's like a one week ski school
that is only built for people
who need like a week of snow.
You know?
- yeah
- And it's like this half
thing phycology resort.
like some people like to go to
a spa for four days intense.
I think that they're afraid of something
called like cleanse with powder.
- Oh my god.
(laughs)
- It's a business that's set up for,
come up to Vermont or Colorado
or where the fuck.
I don't know anything about skiing
but like come here, it's all in a week,
you get seven days of skiing,
whether you're an expert and
we're going double diamond,
or whatever that shit's called
or I probably will help you.
It's 20 people max, you've got all paint X
and it's a day of skiing
and then we all have dinner
together and we all do the shit
and then there's one on one kind of like,
like if you actually
have that helping DNA,
it's kind of like what I'm doing now.
What I didn't realize was I
was gifted with the ability
to come up with a lot
of ideas very quickly
which is why I just did
what I just did now.
Like listen to you--
(software interferes with speech)
And come up with a genuine concept--
The videos in Instagram and YouTube.
Like they're all really work, right?
Like you making videos of like being,
and like you talking about like things
that you like talking about like
pumping our parents or being a
millennial this time or like,
never like don't be like
the ways for this business to move like.
And I'll give you a business before
you even give a reaction to both of us.
- Yeah.
- I don't talk about a lot of
things are just not my lane.
I speak all the time in my lane, right?
And so I think of business around fear
can you only be helping
people by being a lending ear
and getting a little community.
Is it viable?
- Absolutely, I very much
agree with you there.
Now, you know how you always talk about
the whole Lake, like screw money concept,
like money isn't happiness, right?
So I did a good job in getting in a good
amount of student debt.(chuckles)
So I've been playing that
game so when I hear that,
I know some folks who would do that.
I mean, there's no reason I
couldn't do it better, right?
But, I could see it being a constrictive,
like not being able to essentially
afford my current situation.
You follow me?
- Of course I follow you.
So couple of things that
run through my mind.
Look, you're talking to somebody who
for 12 years of his life,
did something he thought he needed to do
and at 34 started over
and did his life, right?
- Yup.
- I Needed, my parents didn't pressure me.
I needed it for me as a man,
to go into that and build it
up for my parents, I needed it.
I was so grateful for them and
I wanted to do it so badly.
You know, if you have
to spend seventy years
eating crow in a high paint,
to clear that debt 'cause--
(software interferes with speech)
there's nothing wrong with me.
And then starting fucking,
you know, to scoop the powder.
- Yup, that's true.
Hey, I like that name better.(laughs)
- I'm trying to iterate here.
There's also the ability
to go and literally ask
every person you know,
for five, 10, $15,000
to be able to raise capital.
Ask a thousand people and get 10 yeses.
Now you've got a little bit of
a base to start the business.
And if the business
isn't the right business,
all of a sudden you're using the profits
to clear off your college debt.
That's a more offensive move than
the a defensive move or a sales job.
There's just a lot of
ways to attack right.
I don't think there's any right way.
There's just the right way
for Charles in his DNA.
And as in you have fucking eighty years
in front of you is a really big cycle.
- Yeah, i know.
Thank you for that.
I love your patience message.
That just made me think of something.
Do you want me to let yo know?
- Lets stick at it.
- Appreciate it.
So I got laid off two
weeks ago for my sales job.
I missed this whole thing.
And basically what my plan was today
is I made a list of sales
leaders at companies
I'd like to work for and
I was going to cold call
and sell them on myself,
do you think that's a good
move in this time right now
or do you think it's insensitive?
- I'm a big fan of a
customizable cold email
and LinkedIn and cold DM and cold call.
But when people do that
9% of the time always
99% of time because they
don't make it contextual
to that person.
So when you are old
Thompson, make sure you're
on the internet, talk in a good way.
(software interferes with speech)
Do your homework on her.
(laughs)
and understand, if your email title
starts with like, you know,
just like Albert to host, I
can hit home runs for you.
That matters.
- Yeah.
- And then for homework,
like people are always like,
I'm going to help you buy the jets.
Delete cause it's, I hear
that a million times.
Now, Carol May not hear anybody
ever mentioned the Cardinals.
So I think it's a great idea.
Charlie I think you know,
sitting around and dwelling
is a bad idea, fucking do
it yourself is a great idea.
I think I'm trying to make
sure you actually get the job
and so I think you have to
do the extra 15 to 45 minutes
of research of the other person
call to be more effective
cause going forward of age
(software interferes with speech)
- Yeah, no, absolutely I appreciate that.
Thank you Gary.
- Well brother, have a great day.
- Yeah you too, take care.
- While we transition to the next call,
I just want to give a huge
shout out to blueberries.
I think dealers are
mostly grossly underrated.
And so there's that.
Yes.
I do.
- Good morning.
- How are you doing?
- Hey, I'm good.
I'm all the way in Southern Oregon,
So it's early here.
Like when you talk about
self awareness all the time,
I'm just like,
it blows my mind cause I just feel like
I've always been there and
it's awesome to be here.
So I just wanna give a
shout out to your team
because I know how much
work it is to do audio
and video work, so just props to them.
Anyways, so my question
as a parent actually,
every year I kind of pick like a word
instead of like a thing that's
like a new year's resolution,
I guess you could say.
And my word this year is gratitude.
so I've been thinking a lot
about instant gratification
with like internet.
We're able to get on our phones,
we can get into anything.
And I know you love technology.
I love technology,
but with our kids they
can get on our phones
and just do anything and go anywhere
and get it instantly.
And we didn't have that life
so we didn't know how good it is.
How do we show our kids that gratitude
and how good we have our lives daily.
we have such good things
always happening kinda just like easily.
- Well, you know what's
funny to your point,
we didn't have the internet,
or the speed of which what we had,
but like we had the BCR
and our grandparents thought we were lucky
we hadn't Nintendo and our
parents thought that was crazy
cause they had to go to the arcade.
So, to me, I don't think
getting kids to be grateful
is the product of getting
and making them feel lucky
about what they have because
that's just the reality.
I think gratitude comes from actually
de-valuing things other
than health and happiness.
I think the old school
grandmas and grandpas
that would just choose to
live health and happiness
had it down.
I think, that's what I spend time on.
So to me it's really more about
- [Woman] Subpoena court.
- To me--
- Not good, she's seen the
good things going down.
- To me I think it's about clapping up
and making a bigger deal
of like time together.
Like I think parents are not patient
about the deposits
they're making with kids.
Like if you celebrate dinners together,
if you celebrate just talking, hugging,
if you celebrate the right things,
those things are being
instilled in your kid.
What parents struggle with
is that they don't see
the instant results of that.
- Long term, it's always long term.
- I think what parents
struggle with is they want
like their kids to like flip
the switch and be grateful.
See, now that there's Corona,
be grateful for what you have
and that you have a roof over your head.
The reality is it's just not how it works.
You need to do is instill gratitude around
not an X box or you have a
roof over your head around
like we love each other.
Thank God everybody's
healthy, we love each other.
Thank God everybody's healthy
and you just stay consistent
and then let them, when they're
27 they kind of over one
night over dinner they're like,
"Hey mom, thanks for doing that."
And that's it.
Like I think most parents are
looking for instant results
from kids and kids are not
those kinds of animals.
You'll see them, you'll see
the results of that good work,
that consistent deposit
of the right perspective.
You'll see that in their
twenties and thirties.
- Right, yeah I definitely feel that
cause I'd say to my parents, I'm like,
"I get it now."
Cause my, trying to discipline
the you out of your own kid
is like,
(mimics loud explosion)
- [Woman] It's so frustrating.
- Like damn it.
I remember doing that same thing and
it's also putting those
things into perspective.
I think a lot of parents over worry about
other parent's opinions.
Like I think what my
mom did extremely well,
that I'm focused on is, if I believe it
and then that's what it is,
not if I'm worried about
what the fellow teachers
or other parents are
going to say about it.
- Yeah, I know that's kind
of what my word last year
was kinda like forgiveness,
forgiving myself or like
what you talk about,
putting yourself in self imposed jail.
I put too many freaking expectations
on what my Parent had and what my life
was supposed to be and then,
all of those like came
crashing to hold me,
'cause you know how it is with kids,
nothing you ever thought was
gonna work is what happens.
Nothing you ever thought was
going to be the way it was
is what it is.
Everything that you put
in as far as expectations
with the child is definitely changed by
They're coming into the world.
(laughs)
- And the other thing--
(software interferes with speech)
delivered in that sentence
is need to fucking realize
your life has kind of
weirdly just started to.
- Oh yeah.
(software interferes with speech)
- no, no, no in a good way.
And I'm like, no, no.
Like you know, the way
it was supposed to be
or things of that nature.
Like we actually have a lot
more time to make shit happen.
And I think that when we're ideological
at 16, 13 or 12 we're
thinking about 20, 30, 40.
But there are (software
interferes with speech)
you know Colonel Sanders,
the guy created the "Grey Goose",
Darryl corn, a lot of these people
started their true calling
in their 40s, 50s, 60s, 70s and 80s.
- Yeah, I tell myself that all the time
because I mean I'm about to be 35
and I got my bachelor's
degree in costume design.
So that's my other thing.
(software interferes with speech)
- I'll let you finish,
but you have to hear this.
- Yeah.
- I started being at media at 34
and started in another
company's conference room
cause I didn't have enough money.
- No, it's totally,
I keep thinking that I'm like you, Oprah.
I keep telling myself this is the time
where I can get started
in and buckle down.
Because my perspective is totally focused
in the right direction
now because I realize,
my kid is everything to me and if I want
her to do what she wants
to do in life and be happy
in that world, I have to do it.
If I don't show her that I love what I do,
she's not gonna see that
and she's not gonna
wanna do the same thing.
I wanna give her the confidence
by having the confidence in myself.
- I love that, that's
the actual right answer.
- (chuckles) Well, I mean
that's self-awareness.
I'm the second of six kids.
I watched like my siblings do it.
My dad's school of hard knocks.
He built houses, zoned out on job sites
and as a kid in Florida it was hot,
I was like, I want to
work smarter, not harder.
I loved construction.
I love watching things work.
So I just wanna show
her that she can build
anything she wants to.
- I love that, good for you Jane.
it's really cool.
I'm really glad we connected,
- Right sure Gary will be
connecting more I just feel it.
- I'll talk to you soon.
- Bye Gary.
- Thanks for getting up so
early in order to do this.
- Hey, I wanted to--
(software interferes with speech)
Okay.
Hello?
Hey, deadly tarantula girl, are you there?
- What's up, Gary?
- What's up bro, how are you?
- I can't see you, but I'm good.
- You can't see me.
- I can now.
- Awesome, how are you bro?
- I'm good, glad you got
your stock of blueberries.
- Yes, I need blue berries.
I also got some raspberries also wild.
- That's critical, that's critical.
Master make some good wine.
Yeah, thanks for taking the time.
So yeah that might be a
little legacy story to this,
but basically I'm 37 and
started an ant farm competition
on Tik ToK.
- Wow.
- And exactly, it's the same thing I get
from everybody else.
So we went from zero to 70 K followers
In the span of maybe
like two to three weeks
and then now it's kinda around 70
going into the first month.
You wanna see it?
- Yes.
- All right, here we go ready?
There's the ROXA and there's the box
okay, the box, of course
got Rosa, Antonius in there.
Okay, we got Forky.
Yeah, it's an ant farm basically.
It's pretty much the
funniest thing in the world.
(software interferes with speech)
- Hear me yelling at a screen
about Tik Tok and jumped in
or was there a different
reason you jumped in?
- Yeah, so I've been hearing you
for the past four or five years.
I started a little a hundred
day workout challenge
and about a year ago just
listening to you listen
to a podcast pushing your podcast.
I learned a ton from that.
Got over the fear of looking in the camera
like I am right now.
So this is really hard for
me but it's really fun.
So the 100 day challenge kind of helped me
get through the fear of
looking at the camera.
And I've been looking at Tik
Tok for like three, four months
and I'm like, you know what,
the office is doing an
Ant farm competition
just for like lowering stress.
We just getting a bunch
of these ant farms,
having fun looking at ants and
it's like a really good way
just to get out of the day to
day like software industry.
I work with a partner for SAP
and implementing basically ERP
software for process manufacturing.
So it's definitely a job
and this is just fun.
So it started as a side thing.
I've just been looking
as you've mentioned,
just looking into Tik Tok
and just kind of watching
and just basically just
looking at the content.
And seeing where this
would fit and like where
would ant farms fit?
And then nobody's doing what I'm doing.
Its just basic, but that's
kind of what I was going for.
It's long form, it's one minute.
A lot of things are 15 seconds on Tik Tok.
I'm actually building an
audience and it's a lot of fun
and people are enjoying it.
And I'm finding the Tik Tok community,
even though its a little
younger, very authentic.
They really appreciate common thing.
- I love that and are you
thinking about turning it
into a viable business?
- (chuckles) You know what,
like I've been tasting
for quite some time.
As you've mentioned, like
I got into martial arts
for 10 years, I made a song
for the hedgehog video game,
played poker online.
I'm all over the board.
So I've been trying to, yeah
so I'm trying to find
the things, go ahead.
- Would you view that as positive?
I mean that (software
interferes with speech).
- Yeah, I've been trying
really hard to find
like what is the actual
thing that makes me tick.
- You do view that as a positive,
the poker and the Sonic.
- 100%.
- Because a lot of people
I think take the judgment
of others who are like,
"Oh, you're always trying random shit,
" like boggled down."
And you know, like all those conservative,
straight-laced, stay in
the pocket, you know,
misery loves company
voices that we all have
in our lives that are always--
- 100%
- Carry too much weight.
So I'm proud of you for realizing
and doing all that random shit.
The effort and humility
to find actual happiness
is huge bravery and something
I just admire quite a bit.
So good for you.
- Thank you sir.
So yeah, so basically getting into this
and I just basically took the plunge
and just put it on Tik Tok
and just had a ton of fun with it
and people were really
grasping to it, which is great.
So now we're at 70 K and yeah,
could I have a viable business
that I'd go to like monetize it somehow.
Actually I could.
Had some of the ant farm companies
reaching out to me, like,
"Wow, we quadrupled our sales,
" like what the heck is going on?"
But for me I have a full time job
and I have three kids and
a two month old upstairs
and the kid just got up.
So I'm doing this at nighttime.
I'm basically taking quick videos
or I'm on conference calls just like this.
And then I'm making funny voice
and just having a great time.
I'm having the most fun I've ever had.
So the growth is there, the
naysayers are definitely there
and I'm happy to say,
"Hey, you know what?
" Guess what, I'm having fun."
And now the naysayers are coming around.
- Who are the naysayers?
Like publicly anonymous
naysayers or like--
- No internal, like more just my circle,
which is crazy.
- And what's the nay say?
(software interferes with speech)
- It's not so much this,
I mean, it's more of like
any of the little dumb things I wanna do.
It's like the little nag, like
the a hundred days challenge.
Oh, why are you wasting your time on that?
Just maybe general around
the people I'm around.
So it's like,
"why are you wasting time there
"why waste time on your business?"
You've got three kids, you know,
so I'm finding time, it's fine.
It's getting traction
now people are like, wow,
they're paying attention
to the ants, you know.
It's kina funny.
So where do I go from
here is the question.
- You definitely go on YouTube.
You definitely, definitely, definitely
have to make YouTube videos.
You have to.
You definitely go on Facebook.
Even though people don't think
about Facebook these days,
I think there's well, opportunity there.
I think you go on Twitter.
You won't get the viral
growth anywhere else.
This is why I kept(software
interferes with speech)
laugh my fucking lungs I'd go on Tik Tok.
- You can get a good jab.
- How many videos a day
are you putting on Tik Tok?
- At least three to four.
Basically, I've been following your exact,
like I watched your timing's on Tik Tok
and I just post right after you basically.
- Listen, you know I've said it a bunch.
Watch what I do, not what
I say I appreciate that.
- I know, that's what I'm doing.
- So where do you go from here?
I think there's a lot of places
you can go from here.
If I was in the business
with you and we were buddies
from high school and you're like,
"okay Gary, you're a fucking
good business student,
"help me."
I would first like,
if everything went perfect,
if I was the fucking ant
farm genie of the future,
and I could grant you the wish.
- yeah
how would you wanna monetize
this part of the world?
Do we wanna sell $90 kits?
Do we wanna have a referral business?
Do we wanna make you famous
so you're giving presentations
at kids' birthdays,
(software interferes with speech)
that I'm most passionate about is,
for example, that last one.
For a lot of people that's like
silly or like sounds stupid,
but like you know how happy some magicians
and performers at kids' parties are?
and I know there's some characters
that have gone onto
build viable businesses.
Some of them are doing
two, 300,000 in appearances
and do about half a million
between YouTube ads and kits they sell
and they fucking love magic.
- That's cool.
- They love kids so I
think for me it comes down
to the number one place.
There's two things you do for sure.
One is you distribute the
content in other places,
even though they have much smaller growth,
they lead to other opportunities.
(software interferes with speech)
press on CNN, which Jen
changes your awareness.
YouTube leads to a search result that pops
and now you're going you have a one video
that has a million views
on it in four years.
That really is your awareness.
There's a lot of different reasons.
People are too caught up
just in following the
account without realizing
a lot of other things that
go into success on social,
which is really in which leads to brand,
which leads to business.
But I think the biggest
thing we need to figure out
is in a perfect world,
how do we turn this into
something that--
To me I would literally,
this is where I don't wanna
put your business out there.
You're more than allowed
to share if you want,
but it would be how much do you make
in a year and how do we get to that number
with the ant farms so that
you could actually do this full time?
I really think that way.
- Yeah, I know.
I couldn't really disclose
how much I make obviously.
But yeah, for sure
the process manufacturing ERP space
takes up a lot of time.
And it's a service based business
I know, you know.
And I'm trying to.
(software interferes with speech)
- I said Pete was is in the same building
as VaynerMedia in New York.
So I know(software interferes with speech)
- I showed up and tried
to knock on your door.
It didn't work.(laughs)
- I mean, I think extra hours,
I mean this is fucking crushed up.
- That's what I'm doing, yeah.
- Wrap question?
- I have your signed copy,
Thank You 62nd Quarter.
- I mean that book was
written 12 years ago
and you're literally living that life.
- I am.
- You know, you've got a two month old
maintain your real life,
take every hour you can on the
side and build this thing up.
But then bro, just the authentic happiness
you're talking about with
the CFR thing by the way,
fuck the authentic story of putting it.
Like if you came up like I think you
could build a multimillion
dollar B2B business
of HR executives buying ant farms.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And because your story is
authentic, like we did this,
like if your story day in and day out,
just like the reason I
won an entrepreneurship
was I was a purebred entrepreneur,
in the 80s; lemonade, baseball.
We started this to get
a seven to 12 minute
mental healthy break and--
(software interferes with speech)
I could see you selling
unlimited amounts of these ant farms
to HR executives on LinkedIn.
I mean you should make
LinkedIn only videos.
Are you in a place yet where you can sell
some of these ant farms or other people
have them and that's why
their sales have gone up.
Have you struck an affiliate sales deal?
Have you thought about building your own?
- So I have struck a small
affiliate sales deal.
It's not fully inked yet,
but basically that's already happened.
I just reached out.
- I think you should
make a couple of videos
from LinkedIn be authentic as fuck.
Like literally the videos, like
"Hey LinkedIn, this is me.
"I'm at this ERP--"
like you know
"This is the ant farm.
"Let me tell you the story."
Like literally story time, story time.
Even talk about and now I bized up,
now I have an affiliate deal
and here's the link to those people.
Like be completely
transparent with the audience.
I would want 20 to 50 of those.
One for HR executives,
one for the individual
stay at home business person.
I would make 20 to 50 LinkedIn videos.
This is the perfect growth.
This Corona virus is a blessing
- It's crazy.
- It's a blessing.
It's gonna force people to try new shit
that they would have never gotten to.
Actually, you know how mad this is,
I've been talking about a morning show
called "Tea with Gary D. QnA show."
For fucking four years
and this is real.
I'm forced to do Something
that I want to do
that I haven't been able to do.
So I would definitely
do the LinkedIn thing
just to see what happens.
- Yup, yeah. I started LinkedIn,
I got my little light
kit I started to make
like ERP tips videos just
to get myself out there.
- I love that.
Have you seen anything,
any traction yet, how many have you done?
- I just started like legit,
just started two days ago.
So it's working.
(software interferes with speech)
- Send email like a week or two
and just put ant farm, I'll read it.
- 100%, hey, one quick thing.
When I come to New York, can
I come value at NES hockey?
- Are you good at it?
- Would I even ask that question
if I didn't have that cred?
- I'm in.
send an email right now to Gary@livemedia
And put anty ass ant farm and I'll get Lou
to take care of it.
- You're the man, hey, one
of the last quick thing.
So my amt farm thing is
like a bachelor meets
the hunger games meets
like me being Steve Hart
of Steve Hart or Steve Duran,
like, should I just stay on that track,
Just have a ton of fun?
- Listen, I don't know if you heard it
when you we were talking about
getting over being on camera.
I said quickly while you were
talking, you're good at it.
I think you're good at it.
- Okay, have you watched one? (chukcles)
- I've been watching how
you're you interacting here
and I do (software interferes with speech)
it gives me enough--
- I appreciate it.
- Well I think, yes.
- All right,bro.
- Cool, We'll save time
to do this, thanks Gary.
Have a good day, take care.
- Lot of fun, let's keep it going Dustin
I saw (software interferes with speech)
What's your name?
- Hey, can you guys see me?
Can you guys hear me?
- I think we now do, how are you?
- I'm doing great, how are you guys?
- Super well, what's your question?
- So I have been working
in the exotic animal.
- (software interferes with
speech) your question like,
all I wanna do is go on that bookshelf
behind you and look up
all these items on eBay.
(laughs)
stuff I love that.
- That's my cherished reference library.
- I love that, it looks awesome
- Thank you so much.
My husband and I have been
in the exotic animal hobbies
since the 90s.
We started our YouTube channel
about seven years ago.
So our initial goal and we
also decided to move from hobby
to business around that time.
So we started our YouTube channel in 2012
and he's the big idea guy
and I'm the detail person.
So together, I consider us
to be quite an Epic force.
And so basically we've
been growing our channels
very, very slowly for a long time
and sort of our backbone has been creating
the highest quality content
possible consistently.
And so our channel has
very slowly grown to 50 K.
so one of the strategies we've been doing,
the last maybe three years
is being super faithful
to our social media.
So that started off really
heavily being Facebook
and now it's moved more toward
Instagram, although I still
do post to Facebook daily.
And then starting in December
after we kinda got hooked
to listening to you in the fall,
we also started on Tik Tok.
And all of that's growing very slowly,
but we had a video go somewhat viral
last year and so that kind of,
that grew us from about
20 K to maybe 40 K.
I wouldn't say quickly but
within four months maybe,
and now we're at about 50.
- At YouTube got it okay keep going.
- On YouTube yeah.
So basically we feel like
our growth has really
kind of come to a skidding halt.
And we just kind of want to know,
where you would suggest we go from here.
- Okay, so couple things.
So the growth is not
necessarily a skidding halt.
If you started at seven years
ago and less than a year ago,
you had a video that more than
doubled your reality, right?
- Okay.
- I think the growth of that
viral video has maybe stopped,
but if you look at it in the macro,
you've had more growth in the last year
than you did in six years prior combined.
So you're--
- okay.
- You probably have more
growth going on right now
than you've had for seven years.
- Yeah, good point.
- Well, that's number one.
Putting into perspective number two is
I'm less worried about how
many subscribers one has.
I'm more worried about
what one wants out of it.
And so how that works.
So is your hope and dream
that you have millions of subscribers
so that the ad revenue from YouTube
is the monetization
or are you hoping to
monetize in a different way
or is your business good enough
and this is more of
competitive vanity part of it
that you want the following to be higher.
- Okay, so our ideal hope
for YouTube is twofold.
Number one, to grow our business.
And number two, I'm sorry.
- What is the business?
- Oh, so our is we breed
and sell exotic animals,
primarily reptiles and
invertebrates mainly tarantulas.
- Well it goes through the awareness
people reach out and by tarantulas
and other reptiles from you.
- Yes and to educate is
kind of our primary goal,
but to monetize the atin of our channel
to grow and also to grow our business.
At this point, my husband and I
are both still working full time.
He works in the medical field.
I'm a school teacher.
So our next phase is basically probably
for him to start running
the business full time.
It's not supporting itself at this time.
Another thing we started
was an only fans account
and that's gone pretty well so far.
So that's actually
bringing in some revenue.
So that's also been kind of
interesting 'cause we have kind
of a fan base that's more a fan of me
than the business.
so yeah, that's been interesting.
I model and dance and so that's been,
like basically I just
started that in December
and our fans have already paid for
us to go to Chicago for our next trip
for a big reptile expo.
So that's been a whole another separate,
thing which we're we're trying.
So long story short,
we would want our channel to grow in order
to bring revenue from our channel.
Also to educate, to grow our
business and bring in revenue.
- How many hours have
you spent on trying to,
get educated on titling and thumbnails
of your videos on YouTube?
How many hours have you
or your husband put in?
- Together probably 20,
which sounds like a real
shame in all these years.
- Honestly, you'd be
surprised how many people
are seven years in and are at zero.
So A, I would definitely
spend more time on that.
- Okay.
- 20 to 45 minutes every day.
Just work up on that.
I do think Facebook ads would work.
Have you tried those yet?
- We haven't.
- Okay, so I do think Facebook ads
have a sneaky potential
Facebook ads work extremely well.
Let me ask you a question.
Are you more interested at this point
to grow the fan pitch
subscription business
or the selling of the reptiles,
if you like, had your way?
- Definitely selling the reptiles
is certainly more of an interest.
And I would be a little bit
sad if our reptile business
never became successful,
but we can support our hobby
because I was modeling.
I mean, that would be great
but ideally our business would,
I'm just kind of doing
that in the meantime.
Andd also too, I'm not young,
so I don't know how long
that's gonna keep afloat.
- so, I think that,
I think running ads of incredible photos
of translators and reptiles
on Facebook and finding the
right target.
I mean, is it a business,
I'm guessing here, is it
predominantly male buyers?
- Of course.
- So like is there an age group
or is it really running gamut?
- So it does kind of run the gamut.
So it's, I would say though,
predominantly like late
twenties to mid forties.
- Yeah, so this starts exciting me, right?
Like you start going on
Facebook, you go 25 to 42.
- Mh hm.
- There might be some interest paid.
You know that you could wrap this to.
I don't know if there's, you
know, I don't know if it works
on whether it's believed this or not,
whether there's bands that over,
like are people that are into metal
more likely to also collect.
I'm trying to think of like crossover--
- Crossover, yeah there's
definitely with like rock music
and tattoos and reptiles
and things like that.
- I would run like a Facebook ad against
25 to 40 year old fans of Harley Davidson
and then run the tarantula photo,
like the best photo you can come up with
and then a video ad and then a picture ad.
I think Facebook will surprise you.
Instagram ads too, I think
Instagram and Facebook, think about this,
you have very visually
interesting product.
Like if you're into this,
that's going to stop you in your screen.
When you see the photos of.
There's a scalable sales,
it's very simple.
I have no idea how much profit
you make on per tarantula?
But how much is a tarantula?
- I mean, they can vary
wildly from $5 to $400.
- So let's say that there's
$100 tarantula that we make,
I'm just gonna make this up,
We make $50 (software
interferes with speech)
- Okay.
- You can find that Facebook ad
that costs you $23 to convert somebody,
AKA it costs you $2 and 30 cents
per every interest click and
one out of every 10 people.
Thus you're spending $23 to get them,
but you're making $50 in profit,
you just start running the
fucking ads as heavy as you can.
That is what you're looking for
in a Facebook and twitter environment.
I believe that's sitting there for you.
It's gonna take the ability to figure out
that it's 25 to 37 year
old Harley Davidson fans.
You've gotta figure that out,
but once you've got that,
it can become quite scalable.
- Okay.
- Awesome, hope you have a great--
- So its,I was just wondering
is there like a specific
like search engine technique or website
that you use to try and get that data?
- No, it's about actually coming up with
the ideas like we just did here.
The Facebook ad product,
you go into the ad program
on the back end of both
Facebook and Instagram,
you go to ads and you'll see the selectors
and the queries and the
way to navigate that.
No different than when you used to buy
SEO ads or anything like that.
- Okay awesome.
Well, I just want to say I'm a big fan
and I'm so honored that you took the time
to answer my question personally today.
You're the man.
- Thank you, have a great day.
- Thank you, you as well.
- Lets keep this going.
Awesome.
Great.
- Can you hear me?
- How are you?
- Good, how are you?
Can you hear me?
- Well.
- Hey, guy what's up?
- Good mate.
- Hey man, first of all, a
moment of gratitude, man.
You know, I've been consuming your content
for a little bit, not too, too long,
but I just wanna thank you
from the bottom of my heart
because I feel like
you've given away so much,
just free information is
so much value to people.
It's been amazing to
listen to this information
and then some of it is just motivational.
You know you're a big reason
why I just started my YouTube channel
and Instagram channel
about exercise and fitness.
And listening to you, I realized, why not?
Well, what is holding me back, you know?
So just thank you so much man.
I really appreciate it man.
- You're welcome bro.
- My first question pertains to quality
versus quantity of content that you post.
I just got a PDF off your website,
about 64 pieces of content that
you recommend people put on,
on a daily basis, so I wonder
where do you find that balance?
How do you determine content
quality versus quality?
- So for me, quantity
is not debatable, right?
Meaning...
Hold on one second.
Quantity is not debatable.
(software interferes with speech)
19, 18, that's the number.
Quality is very debatable, right?
You know, for example, where
some people that don't think
that, wouldn't mind the
quality of this right not.
I'm not using lighting, yesterday
was a lot of on Twitter.
They're like, Gary you look terrible.
I'm like, no, just lighting.
And I have bags under my
eyes because my family's DNA,
you know, Eastern European shit.
You understand that you're eastern,
you know, you're like to
me, quality is subjective.
People overthink quality
on production value.
I think quality is based on the words
coming out of my mouth right now.
So for me, the way I look at it is
people use quality often
as an excuse not to do.
Its the thing they say
because they don't actually
wanna put themselves out there.
And quantity is not debatable
and quantity is more at bats.
And I think it is a volume
game on the internet
because of the nature of the internet.
So for me, how do I balance it?
I don't put out anything that
I don't think is quality,
but I don't think production value
or image quality is quality.
I think the message and
the words are the quality,
not the package, It's deliberative.
- Understood, understood.
The next thing is the brand name itself.
Obviously building a brand is so important
today in today's world.
So just to give you an
example, the YouTube name
is "Learn to exercise",
but the Instagram name,
"Learn to exercise" is taken.
So how important it is to
have the exact same name?
Is it okay to have some
underscores and things in the name?
- That's okay, names and handles are made.
I'm Gary Vee with two
silent Es, that's not smart.
It should have been Gary V and no E-E
but I made it through my actions.
McDonald's sounds like an Irish pub,
not like you know, what does Nike mean?
What does Google mean?
They don't mean anything
until the person makes it.
And so for me, I think that
brands are made and handles.
People will find what
they're actually looking for.
so I'm not crippled by
having different things.
I prefer you have the same
it's easier for customers,
but I don't think it's devastating.
I would also argue that
your name is generic.
Like right, it's just generic.
And I think too many people
think in search terms
and try to think too technical
instead of making a name.
I'd rather be called Yuri's exercise
cause it's ownable and it's more distinct
than for it to be a generic term.
But that's your choice.
But I think to answer
your question directly,
I'm not crippled by a
different Twitter handle
or Instagram handle.
"Winetexts", a platform that
I have for my dad's business,
which is going really well.
All the social handles are "Winetexts"
with an extra S because we
couldn't get "winetext".
So we had to force.
We even had to buy the URL with an S
'cause we knew the social
handles were gonna have an S.
So you know, "winetexts".
So I'm not crippled by that.
I think it's the execution.
- Got you.
And another thing too, you just said
you like to try new shit.
(laughs)
Sorry I didn't wanna say that.
So I was just wondering,
would you be willing to try a 30 day
Karent in training with Gary V
like an online type of training?
- I wouldn't.
Just 'cause, you know,
I appreciate the question.
I appreciate the right hook.
I think for me it's,
I don't like to put my name
behind stuff that I don't control
nor I'm passionate about at that moment.
So that's why I wouldn't but
I appreciate your asking.
- Thank you man I really
appreciate it, brother.
Take care man.
- Peace out.
Thank you so much, talk to you soon.
Awesome.
Brad, how are you?
- I'm very well, how are you Gary?
- I love the mariners shirt
bro, that's fucking fresh.
- Yeah man, I gotta keep
that baseball alive, man.
While we got a little downturn bro.
- I know bro, my fantasy baseball draft
is like my favorite thing in the world
and it was literally
supposed to be yesterday,
so it was like in this sad state.
- So what's up?
- So I took your advice.
About nine months I stopped watching you.
- Good.
- And about two years ago
I started my own business.
I got it from that--
(software interferes with speech)
- A lot of fans reached out to me.
They're like, bro, I stopped watching you.
And then like three
months I'll get an email
and they're like,
"so listen, when I stopped watching you,
"I started watching this and this stuff
"and actually it was crap.
"And then I spent $10,000
on this mastermind."
And I'm like,
"No, no, no.
"Stop watching it."
The theory act on all the stuff you know.
So anyway, hopefully that means
you went into action mode.
- Yeah, that's absolutely right.
So, it came from that San Diego video
that you just ranted on that hotel room.
And I told myself when
I was employee back then
that I would, when I
become an entrepreneur,
I would definitely stop
watching Gary and act.
So, two years ago started my own business
with a partner of mine.
And as I tested and tried a
bunch of things along the way,
I found out what I was doing was actually
what I really loved, you know.
So I started a sales and
marketing business around
architectural building products
out here in Seattle.
So there's a lot of action going there.
I have a good strong network
and we were preparing
for the last four or five months to expand
and go from three employees
to four employees.
So we are super, super new
and I was about to make
the move this month
and then all of a sudden,
there is this.
The biggest lesson I've learned
over this entrepreneurial journey
it's sure, there's a lot
of things I know how to do
and I can analyze and I can get there,
but there's this grit, right?
This entrepreneur thing takes, right?
There's this grit of like--
- I called it (software
interferes with speech)
the stomach for it.
- Yes.
- It's a different breed
then people don't realize
like it's this anxiety.
You have to have the
ability to have a stomach,
its anxiety 24/7 365 you're a firefighter,
you're a firefighter
like you're always on.
There is no vacation.
I mean, do you understand how
chill I would be right now
if I was in college or in high school?
I'd be pumped with this greatest...
I keep thinking like, fuck!
Why didn't Corona happen in 1993?
If I had three months off of school,
I would've lost my
fucking mind in happiness.
(laughs)
Now that I'm a grown up
and I have a thousand
employees to take care of
and I've got all of this
shit on my shoulders.
- No, that's exactly right.
I mean, and then talking with
these perspective employees
and trying to basically craft
and listen to their awareness
and then understand like,
"Hey, this is ours and
this is what we're gonna be
and then this thing hits.
And along the way, I'm just
thinking the entire time
while everybody is zigging I zag, right.
There's an opportunity
here that I don't know
if I'm super clear on yet,
but I do still feel that gut feeling
of to expand while there's
a perception of contraction in place.
You know what I mean?
- I mean the amount of fortunes,
and when I say fortune I
mean happiness and finance,
fortunes that are gonna be made
during this next 12
week period is enormous.
- Right.
- It's using the Seahawks
metaphor instead of a Mariners,
most people are gonna
go into prevent defense
and give up a touchdown.
I'm going to blitz and create a sack
and scoop the football
up and score and win.
I think that's right.
Now the reason I'm going to blitz
is because I've done all the right things
for the last decade,
to have a secondary
that's gonna protect me,
AKA, for anybody who doesn't
follow the football analogy,
I can go on the offense right now
because I've left a lot
of money on the table
over the last decade because I've saved.
(software interferes with speech)
On the flip side, to your point,
like let's say you haven't saved,
if you're just starting,
yes, there's enormous
opportunity you need to be able
to get through three or
four months here clearly.
And I think, you know, looking at China,
looking at South Korea,
looking at other places,
this doesn't look like
it's the black plague.
It doesn't look like we're gonna lose
100 million people to death.
- No.
- You know. the government
is clearly scared
and so we'll see huge stimulus packages
and so look,
there's a lot of reasons
to believe of like,
if you can get through
a hundred days of pain,
there might be a lot of
prosperity on the other side.
I think it's practical
to go on the offense
on these under days,
- It's really timely, this conversation.
I've tried, I dunno,
over the last four years
to connect with you in various ways
and for it to come at, like today,
it's incredibly timely.
And there's always this
serendipitous moment for it
and it's just,
man, I want to,
I see that opportunity and I
can see these different cracks
in this place happening
for me and my industry,
we were in that construction industry
that was left behind in 2008 and 10.
Everybody departed, so there's
a strong lack of resources
and trained people to actually do it.
And I've been basically
creating this network
and I've been the only
one to suck them into
like, just work for us and go after it.
And they were all sitting at the precipice
of saying yes and going after it.
Now it's like that grit moment,
that chest moment of like,
I've done my analyzation,
I've done this thing.
It's time to take the leap.
And Gary, that's something that,
you don't read in the
business book, right?
You don't look on Instagram
on, you know, it's, so--
- I'm gonna come in the
form of a quote for me,
I think how I see this, brother, is
life is about alternatives.
- Okay.
- The reason you have to
do it is, if you don't,
in 39 years you're gonna
be sitting on the porch
being like,
"Fuck, why didn't I do it?"
- I'm 39 years old dude, yesterday.
- So happy birthday.
(laughs)
- That was super weird.
You know, and so like what I don't want
is 70 year old you
sitting there with regret.
I'd rather you jump, fail and leap back.
I think people don't understand
how much regret is...
The greatest thing of
talking to 80, 90 year olds,
which I find myself doing
a lot of times in airports
and random shit,
And I'm an old soul and
I've come to know that.
- Me too.
- They spent all their time on,
all they talk about is
the things they didn't do.
- Yeah.
- You look at an 89 year old
in a nursing home right now
and she's gonna tell you like
she wished she married Bobby Thompson
instead of Rick.
(laughs)
And she wishes that she
started the business
but that was not the
era when women did it.
And he's gonna say, you know,
Don's going to say that he
wishes he did move to st Louis
to the big capital.
Nobody ever talks about
the shit they failed.
Everybody always talks about
the shit they didn't do.
- Yeah.
- Women right now.
If you're wrong and you take on this risk
and the business didn't come in
and you've gotta let go
of these and start over,
it's not gonna feel good
and it'll take you a couple
of years to dust yourself off
but you'd be 45 and you'll
move on with your life.
- Right.
- But if you dont, it's
gonna sit there forever
and you're gonna regret forever.
- Yeah.
It makes me emotional
actually thinking about it,
that what changed my
perception with you was
I still think about it is epis..
Or Gary daily, his weekly,
daily V episode 28, "I wish".
And you mentioned again today,
I remember walking through
a sister this living center
that we had designed and built
and done from there and I remember
seeing this 85 year old guy
coming to sit in the lobby.
And I remember I had to sit in the lobby
to wait for this other meeting to happen.
And I just watched him.
This is right after I
watched that episode.
And come him down the elevator,
he walks 15 feet, sits down in the lobby.
And that was his,
that was his walk for the day.
And I remember looking at that
and thinking about the
perspective of really I wish
and going, I do not wanna--
when I'm that guy, there's nothing--
(software interferes with speech)
- Nothing on the field.
And much like, you know,
for everybody who's
listening, I was 28 to 50.
Much like all the things
you thought about as a kid
and now here we are.
You're gonna be that 70 year old,
you're gonna be that 80 year old.
You're gonna be that 90 year old.
- Yeah.
(software interferes with speech)
- And so bro, I think
you're in the right mindset.
And I think that,
this moment is gonna lead
to a lot of opportunity.
And I think you know the answer.
It's very clear to me,
you know the answer,
you know, just don't, you know,
you've clearly analyzed like
how much risk reward, you know,
like if you end up homeless
and things of that nature.
But put yourself in a practical
offensive position and go.
- Practical offensive position.
All right man, I got this.
And one other question.
If there's any other
daily tactics that you do
that just basically take that
mindset and you switch it
'cause there's so many different things
of winds that change during the day?
- Well, my time on worst case scenario.
- Okay.
- That's all I do.
It's funny, it's counterintuitive.
People think I'm so offensive.
All I do every second is
think if this all goes wrong,
am I okay with going back into
a studio apartment in Queens?
And answer is yes.
- Yeah, I just wrote my
wife a letter the other day.
I just said there is no regrets
that I've got over the 15
years that we've been married.
And if I was to do it over again,
the way we did it over again,
I would do whatever it
takes every single day,
all the time.
- I'm Proud of you brother, listen to me.
What I would do is think about
when you hired these four
people or one person.
- Right.
(software interferes with speech)
- go to six and you go for it.
And if the market didn't
respond the way you wanted,
you'd feel bad that you
let those people down
and they have to go back to other jobs.
You have your whole life to make it.
One of the things I spend a lot of time on
is whoever's collateral
damage for my mistakes,
I always think I have my whole
life to make it up to them.
You know, for example,
I never raised capital before,
so when I raised some money for
empathy from all my friends,
my business friends, I've
never said this publicly,
but in my mind I said, if this fails,
I'm just gonna pay them all back.
You know, over time.
- Right.
- 'cause I wouldn't be
able to pay it all at once.
And so like, you know,
you're in control.
- Yes, that's the thing here
is that I've never been in
that position in my life
and I've always told
myself when I'm there,
I know I'm gonna enter with no regrets.
And now that I'm here,
that chest, that grit,
that love that I've got,
it's this really dichotomy
of this motivating factor
but then you feel this like
strain of holding back.
It's a very passionate feeling
and it's just so different to
define, you know what I mean?
- It's being 100% accountable.
It's not having the ability
to blame anybody else.
This is now no longer your
bosses or the company's fault.
(software interferes with speech)
I get it brother, I live it every day
and I've lived in pretty
much my whole life.
so I understand.
Here's the good news,
put it into worst case scenario.
- I think the sentence,
" When this fails, I'll
be happy because I did it
" and then I'll do this and hope"
And if you don't risk the house,
you know, I mean, what?
You buy a $28 Mariners
t-shirts who gives a fuck.
(laughs)
(software interferes with speech)
- I wish you well, Brad.
- Thank you, Gary, much love brother.
- Good bye.
That was a good one.
Awesome let's do it.
Brian what's good.
- Gary, how are you man?
- I think I'm well, Brian.
How are you?
- I'm excellent.
It's pretty amazing actually
to be able to be on a call with you
So I'm pretty excited about that.
- Thank you brother, what's cooking?
- Well, you saw my question,
I sell restaurant point of sale software.
So I help restaurant owners,
you know, make their
businesses more efficient,
help them run their business,
grow their sales and so forth.
And then with the shutdown man,
it's just affecting all of them.
And so I'm just curious as
to what ideas you might have
for them to help them through it.
- I mean, for them
they've gotta re-engineer
their infrastructure to be
able to do local delivery
or if they got the savings,
whether the 100 or 2,500,
this could be for restaurants
and public places.
You could be looking at 3/4 of a year.
Because even when we open back up,
I think there's gonna be hesitation
from you know,
it's gonna be a little
while for public places
to get all the way back
because even if we open
up in three months,
I know my mom and other
people that are like,
you know, kinda scared,
they're gonna be a little
less excited about going.
You know, there'll be a whole group
that couldn't wait to go out.
So there'll be that pent up.
But I don't, it could be a little while
before it gets to even Steven.
So I think there's two things.
One, they've gotta innovate
and they've gotta innovate in two ways.
Either from a branding standpoint
or from an operational standpoint.
Either they build out significant
delivery infrastructure.
So it's not only the ability to have
door dash or Uber eats or,
seamless pickup from them.
It's also the ability to have
the capabilities of prepping those meals
and things of that nature.
But it's also building
up awareness in marketing
so that people choose their restaurant
versus a different one.
And number two, I think
they need to make content.
If I owned a restaurant right now,
I'd be in my restaurant by myself
and I would literally...
If I was a owner chef,
I would literally make a
video of every single dish
we have on the menu
and show how I make it,
why I invented it.
And most likely I
wouldn't have invented it.
I was like, all right,
here's our cheeseburger.
Obviously we need a cheeseburger
'cause we fucking sell
cheeseburgers all day long.
Here's how we think about
it, here's the stove I chose.
You don't clean it that's the top.
You know, how people like
to do that with the grill.
That gives it the extra flavors.
I'm big on tomatoes.
I pick up my tomatoes from Cal.
Hey Cal a big shout out and Cal,
I know you're struggling out
there I love you brother.
Like, I think people
have to tell their story.
I think that...
Then I would go to my bar
and literally be the mixologist
and explain every drink we make.
This is the time to tell your story.
I would make 50 to a 100 videos
of why we started the restaurant,
how long we've been here,
how I negotiated the lease,
my favorite customers, war
stories, classic stories.
Every dish.
This is the time to tell
the world your story.
I think of it right now is this,
I think the coronavirus has caused us all
to be into one huge virtual campfire
in the fucking 1300s.
so we need to go around and
tell each other our stories,
which is what we used
to do pre television,
pre fucking everything radio.
We used to sit around
and tell fucking stories
from the fucking heart and from the brain.
And I think every small business right now
needs to tell their story,
why they started their business,
how they started their business.
War stories, AKA bad
things that have happened.
Hero stories, AKA great
things that happened.
And then go into detail of their business.
I would walk around my fucking
restaurant and be like,
"Here's why we picked these chairs
"I didn't have any fucking money,
"I bought them at a garage sale.
"This sign came for..."
Like tell the world your story
in the form of 50 videos.
The end.
I think everybody should do that.
- 100% yeah.
I agree we've already been
talking to some people like that.
Like grab your phone, go out
in front of your restaurant.
like we're open, right?
Take them on a tour like you said.
Take them through the restaurant,
show them all the chairs,
sitting up on the tables.
And tell their story show the kitchen.
Show the food all those ideas, yeah.
And for all the owners
that are watching right now
who are introvert and they're like,
" Fuck, I can't do that.
"I'm too scared of the camera.
"I don't like the way I look".
Use an employee.
You know inevitably obviously
we need social distancing
so maybe they need to be
six feet away from you.
But like if your Cook's funny,
if your maître d' is charismatic,
if a busboy who's been
with you for six weeks
just happens to be good at gift of gut.
Maybe you know, a lot of people,
my dad for example, needs
me to be on camera with him
and then he's good.
Bu he doesn't like it or
he's not as capable solo.
So maybe you're the
owner and you just need
a second person to bounce off of
Cause it's, you know,
you gotta find the way
that you become comfortable
but you have to put out
content and communicate.
It is everyone's sitting at home
and you're one viral video away
from changing your business
and more importantly,
you put them on YouTube and you're one,
even if you never go viral,
if you make one video
about your Greek salad
that kinda does well on
search results in your area
in a year from now,
you might be getting 15
new customers a month
just because of the one
Greek salad video you made
that happened to do well
on YouTube or Google.
Ticktock is a huge opportunity right now.
You know, like just get
creative gets silly.
This is about will it succeed 10 X
and that's the way the game is played.
- Yeah, yeah 100%
- The creators over the criers.
- Yeah, you gotta think differently.
You've gotta innovate, you gotta you know.
- Brother like fuck.
Like I've been yelling
about this for a decade.
Like make content for the internet.
(software interferes with speech)
You need to think differently.
Like fucking take your iPhone,
walk into your restaurant
and make 100 videos.
I'm giving you the blueprint
right now, here it is.
Make a video for every single
product you sell on your menu.
Literally make a video for
literally every product
you sell on your menu.
And if you wanna do a "how you make it",
cause you're again an owner chef, great.
If you're an owner and the chef comes in
and some social distance and you make it,
like this is a yes over no.
This is a create over cry.
This is a do over dwell mindset.
All we are so lucky.
If this happened in 1984
there is no internet.
So I think, to all my restaurant friends,
they're like ah, we're so unlucky.
I'm like you're not,
you have the internet,
you have your iPhone, so lucky.
- Yeah, yeah let me ask
you another question
more from my perspective, right?
So I struggle with
I don't wanna be that guy
coming in to try to sell you
a new POS system when you are facing
shutting your business
down or no business at all.
And I've had some of my
contacts tell me, you know,
you have something great to offer
you have a tool that can
help these restaurant owners.
So be that guy but it's all
about how you be that guy.
- Look, I think to your point,
I think you need to make
a decision for yourself.
I would struggle to try
to sell a POS right now.
- Right.
- I would be putting out content,
I would be making videos about, you know,
I would make a video if I'm you right now,
That's titled "Why I'm not
selling my POS system right now".
And I would just make that video.
Be like, Hey,
talk to a bunch of people
now making pretend of me.
Of like talked to a bunch of
my friends and associates.
Ironically serendipitously,
I was on Q and a with Gary B,
and you know, he said it
right for me, you know,
or said it wrong.
He said this, but for me...
It doesn't matter, whatever your truth is.
But I would make a
video saying why I'm not
and you'd say, look,
"I just don't feel like I can right now."
So instead I'm gonna be making videos
about the value of POS.
lik I'm gonna make videos
that are titled like,
Hey, I think you making a
video now of like, hey,
I tried to convince you
because you were old school
and you were like paper and cash
to do POS that didn't work.
Now the coronavirus has hit
and it's hurt your business,
One of the ways business can survive
is you not having inefficient overhead
that a POS system can amortize
out the value over two years.
So, like I would make
content for post Corona now
with your downtime,
I would literally make
a video right now called
"Now the Corona's over,
"It's time to get a fucking POS system."
(laugh)
- People need to like be
more efficient, you know,
or you become the guy who
like literally just gives tips
on things that people could
be doing for their business.
- Well, I'm doing some
of that to try to build
those relationships, you know,
and kind of like,
Hey, listen, you know,
Give.
Like, I can help.
I've got other skill sets
other than selling POS.
I can help you with your Facebook page
and your Google my business page.
We're setting people up
with online ordering.
Like, you should have had all
this stuff in place before
but you didn't and now
you're scurrying to do it
and your eyes are being opened
to new revenue streams
that you'll be able to take
advantage of in the future.
- And some of them are gonna
be sloppy and take shortcuts
and overpay for things, yeah.
Like this is where you
get to be a concierge,
a confidant, a parent
and that then may lead
to you being the person they
choose to do a POS with them.
That's exactly right.
- Yeah, cause there's guys
out there right now that are,
they're doing it wrong.
They're taking advantage of the situation.
They're charging people out the nose
to set up these makeshift
online ordering solutions
and they're not integrated.
And they're not gonna be sustainable.
They're just taking advantage of it.
- Look my blueprints are very simple,
like bring as much value
for free as possible.
And that may lead to serendipity.
If that leads to somebody
hiring the Sasha group,
if that leads to somebody
signing up to One text
IF that that leads to
somebody buying empathy
or my sneakers.
And there's no even expectation.
To me it's just the karma practicality.
Of if you're providing the
most value in the world,
there's going to be things
that work in your favor.
Like, to me,
the amount of people
that I've like changed
their business life who
still go to a supermarket
and buy a $20 wine instead of signing up
for empathy wines is like
that tens of thousands.
And that doesn't even bother me.
Like doesn't even bother me.
Because I've signed up
for karma practicality
and so, yeah, that's
exactly right brother,
I think it'll work.
- Excellent, excellent I
learned a lot from you man.
I appreciate it, thank you.
(software interferes with speech)
Take care.
- Hello.
Hello can you hear me?
- Hey Catherine, how are you?
- I'm good.
I'm really excited.
Thank you, how are you?
- I'm well.
It's good to see you.
Oh my God I'm like freaking out.
I wanna go on that top shelf and look up
all those stuffed animals on eBay.
- (chuckles) A lot of them were web cams
and a lot of them I did sell on eBay
but these are the ones that are left.
- Why do you have a
poster of me on your wall?
- Oh, this is awkward.
(laughs)
- All right, go ahead.
- So my question is basically what advice
you might have for fiction
writers for the internet.
So I've written a few
novels working on more,
don't plan to ever stop.
I'm 20 now.
In high school I thought, I'm
gonna to send out my books,
I'm gonna get an agent and then
it'll all be easy peasy from there.
That didn't happen.
But the more I think about it,
the less sense that
model makes to me anyway
because it seems like you're
giving a lot of leverage
to other people to build
your audience for you
and do everything for you.
And so the last few weeks especially,
I've been really thinking
that just doesn't make sense to me
but I'm really at a loss as
to where to go from here.
(mutters)
- I mean, where you go
from here is you sell,
you obviously print yourself
and you go direct to consumer.
- Yeah.
And so the way, the way I
was thinking about it is
I feel like I have a lot of options.
I'm not sure if I should do
all of them or do one of them.
This has just been occurring to me
in last few weeks (chuckles)
so I've been thinking Wattpad,
just straight to Wattpad.
I've been thinking EBooks
and just messaging everybody
on Goodreads and saying,
"Hey, do you want to read this?"
I've been thinking.
(software interferes with speech)
- well, let's take it up
a level 'cause obviously
you're educated enough to
know Wattpad and Goodreads
and so you're in tactic
knowledge, which is awesome.
Good for you.
Let's go up a notch.
I think what you do is actually get
people to care about characters.
That's how you actually sell books.
What really stands out?
What stands out for me is
can you find a designer or illustrator
and team up with her or him and actually
start Instagram account.
Like for me, if I was
gonna sell, you know,
a fiction book,
I go into the mindset of like,
first let me start the Instagram account
and the Tik Tok account
of Donny the dragon
before I even think
about selling the book.
Because if God forbid AKA God willing,
I can get people to give a
shit about Donnie the dragon
then selling the book becomes
the easier part of it.
So I think what you should think about
is micro little writings.
Let me give you something
that's been on my mind
for a long time for writers
that aren't designers
that don't feel
comfortable or can't afford
or don't know how to
team up with a designer.
Even if you drew stick figures,
like literally you drew a stick figure
and said this is Carol and
then in the Instagram post
wrote 12 sentences and started building up
the profiles of the characters.
You know the functionality
you already know,
you answered to me the functionality
of monetization of direct
to consumer writing.
It obviolooks like you know.
(mutters)
you already got the 101.
The 201 course and really
probably the 301 course
is how do we get people to give a fuck
about those characters before you're even
done with the book.
so that, you know again,
I always say this.
I don't know if you've been
watching, but like the gentleman
who has a fucking ant farm on Tik Tok.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- To me, do you write
towards a certain age group?
'cause Tik Tok is super awesome.
- The most recent one is young adult,
but the older I get, it's more
moving out of that right now.
- Fair enough.
You know, obviously
young adults on Tik Tok
I think has crazy potential.
Even if you just sat and talked about it,
like even if you just made
a video of you just sitting
in this room with this background,
which I think is perfect.
(laughs)
Hey, could be writing a book.
So the story about Sal and Lisa, you know,
like just getting people to
give a fuck is your game.
Not necessarily the functionality
of how not to, you know.
Again, this is what makes me smile.
You already know the different
model than getting an agent
and having Barnes &
Noble and Amazon sell it.
So I don't need to give
you the 101 answer.
I need to get you to think about
how do you get people to care about it.
If I was writing fiction,
I would be putting out content
about the story every day
during the year I was writing the book.
So by the time the book came out,
everybody was dying to read it.
- Oh, that makes a lot
of sense, thank you.
(laughs)
- Yeah, that creatively.
I'm gonna be very weird here.
Even if you took two of the
puppets or the stuffed animals.
(laughs)
I'm not kidding.
And you're like,
hey, I don't know what they're
visually going to look like
but let's just call this Rabbit Steve
and let's just call this, Bear Rock Rock.
This is how I'm gonna do content.
So Steve is talking about.
I don't know what feels
comfortable to you,
but Mr. Rogers was a hit, right?
(laughs)
Like Archie comics was a hit.
I don't know if you can draw,
I gave you the stick figure.
I gave you the straight to camera.
I don't care what it takes.
I don't want you to be reliant
on somebody else to not make,
I need you to make, you need to do, right?
People will dwell that they
can't afford a illustrator.
No, no they can draw stick figures.
People will dwell that they
don't have a great studio,
I'm telling you to fucking
just make videos, right?
Like this, 'cause I think
the background's charming.
Well, people will say they can't.
And I want people to be doers
and I want people to be creators.
Can't needs to be a creator,
dwelling needs to be a doer,
no needs to be a yes and
that's how you get somewhere.
- So I have one that's ready right now.
Do you think there's any,
do you think there would
be any purpose in waiting
or should I get that out and
do the content simultaneously?
- I would probably take 30 days
of trying to build up
content before I released it
to your point 'cause it's ready,
just to even test out my theory.
Look, you know this.
If you put it out now and
you email your email list
and you put that out in all social media
and you spam people on Goodreads,
you're only gonna get
so much action, right?
So the reality is is that
I think you're better off
trying the concept we have
in place of like building up
a little bit of a narrative.
There'll be good muscle for you to learn
how to try to do it.
Makes sense?
I think we might've lost Catherine.
Dustin, we might have lost Catherine?
(software interferes with speech)
Thank you so much.
Let's move on.
- Yeah.
Misael.
- Are we good here?
Hey look, its me and my dad.
- How are you, dad?
(speaks in foreign language)
- He's good
(software interferes with speech)
- Oh man, what's up man?
- I'm just good, bro.
How do you pronounce your name?
- Misael. but you can just call me Mitch.
That's cool.
- Misael is better.
- Sure.
Yeah, I love that name but its just like.
Its easier for other
people to call me Mitch.
But man, this is crazy.
This is surreal man.
This is really sureal.
- Over here too.
This is odd.
So my question is basically,
(mutters)
I've grown up with some great,
and just to give you
context, great parents,
immigrants from Mexico
and they became citizens,
my dad when he was like 20,
and my mom when she was younger.
And basically they raised us,
they raised me and my sister really well
but I felt like from my dad's side,
he did a great job of
structuring stuff and making sure
I have a good work ethic
and stuff like that
but from my mom's side I felt very,
like if life had to be a
lot of fun all the time.
And that created, yeah can you hear?
I can't really hear you.
- I can hear you.
- I'm listening, it's very interesting.
- Okay.
(software interferes with speech)
- He put an emphasis
that life has to be fun.
- My mom did yeah.
She put a big emphasis that the life
like basically that every
moment I couldn't be sad
or that stuff had to be fun
And we never really
complained in the house.
Or anything like that.
- Interesting.
- But what's happened is there's been,
and I've kinda gotten out of this
'cause I started watching a
content a couple months ago,
but basically I got to a
point where my dad took away
my allowance and I felt
like I deserved it.
Yeah, you know what I mean?
You getting it?
- Yeah.
- And I was like--
- When did this happen?
- This happened maybe year and a half ago,
maybe
- How old are you?
- If not a year ago.
I'm 18.
And basically it got me,
it got me feeling wierd now.
I was like,
Well you know, I'm just gonna
have to bear stuff out now.
just whatever.
And my allowance wasn't
that big or anything,
but it just felt like,
maybe it happened like two years ago.
I don't know but...
- You thought that they
were taking advantage of you
that you were entitled to it,
that there was some bullshit.
- Yeah, I felt a little bit like,
wow, they're my parents.
Like they should be
hooking it up a little bit.
You know what I mean?
Yeah It was crazy 'cause...
- what did your dad say?
- What did he say?
He said--
- You're a grown ass
man, no more allowance.
(laughs)
- Basically.
- I liked your dad at the
beginning of this video
and I like him even more now.
- No, he's great.
He's a great dad.
But there was a time when he was,
like what we call them,
(speaks in foreign language)
which basically means the bad guy,
- Of course.
- he was the bad guy
because you know, with my mom
it was all fun and whatever.
(software interferes with speech)
- That's common.
- But now man, I respect him so much
because I started watching your content
and started realizing
that I wasn't entitled
and I was like, what the heck?
'cause I was, it wasn't
only the allowance thing,
but several other little stuff.
And, it just started to liberate me.
But now I'm at the point where
I'm trying to work for him cause,
school got shut down and all that stuff.
And also my schedule is pretty loose
because I'm a senior in high school.
And so I go to school for
like the first half of the day
and then I'll go work
for him the second half
from like 12 to four.
- Love that.
What does he do?
We are ARF, an electrical company,
'cause he's an electrician.
Been an electrician for 28 years,
and so that's where I'm going into.
But anyways,
to get to the actual question,
I'm starting your work consistently,
like a 20 hour work week, soon
to be 40 after I graduate.
And sometimes I find
myself during the week,
like there's days where I love it
and I'm having a good time and whatever,
and there's days that I don't.
And I kinda feel like I'd rather stay home
and play on my drum set
because that's something
that I realized that I kinda like to do.
- Oh you have time to do that.
- Yeah, and that's,
(sighs)
man, this is why I wanna talk to you.
Because I was like,
man, I just don't know.
I'm like you talk about diving
into your passions and stuff,
but I'm like,
I wanna also provide a
support for a future family.
- Yup.
- You know, but then it's like you say
that not everyone's life
is gonna be like yours
and that we can have the
work-life balance if we want it.
- So first of all, back to like
when I think about ingredients,
like you have so many good ingredients.
Like I love your perspective,
you're already at 18, I
like the thoughtfulness.
I love that you're over
the hump on entitlement.
I'm obsessed with the
admiration and respect
you have towards your parents.
You remind me a lot of me at 18 right now
because I just had a lot of that.
I think the one thing
that I was able to do
was I worked a lot more
than you did at this age.
And still thought I did have time
to look at my baseball
cards and play Genesis.
Like I think that my work ethic might've
been more on point than
yours is, to be frank.
- Yeah.
- No, 100%
- We're talking about 50 hours of work
and in that 20 hours you're like,
"Damn, I wish it was on my drum set."
I'm like, mother fucker,
you can be on your drums set
and work these 40 hours.
And even when you said
soon to be 40 hours,
I laughed in my head on some real shit.
'cause I'm like, what do you mean, 40?
Like 40 is different, I was
85, 90 like real fucking hours.
And still I feel like
if you're gonna work 40
you have a ton of fucking
time to fucking bang
on your fucking drums, you know,
and try side hustles and
hang out with friends
and live your life.
40's nothing.
It's nothing.
And what I mean by that
is, you're in a great spot
because you have this,
like if you're talking at
18 about future family,
you got that immigrant
practicality shit in your soul,
which I love.
- What did you say I have?
- You have that immigrant practicality
something in your soul.
You're 18 years old, most 18 year olds
don't think about providing
for a future family,
so I'm glad that you're
in that practical place
but bro, on some real shit, 40's nothing
like 40's nothing
Like I don't even know
how to explain it to you.
I feel like you have an
ability to like have some grit
and eat some Crow and pay your dues.
I've got good news for you, if it's really
40 you got off easy.
Family business, second
generation like shit
usually looks more like 67, 82, 100
like if you're 40 you're
gonna have tons of time
between 18 and 30 to put
into your side hustle
of starting a YouTube
channel arounds drums
to hang out to like,
I mean fucking 40 are
you fucking kidding me?
You fucking hit the lottery if it's 40.
- Damn.
- 40?
I used to work 40 in three days.
My Thursday, Friday and
Saturday of every summer day
since I was 14 was 40.
seven to 8 p.m.
13 hours times three.
like fucking 40?
you're fucking set.
I'm real happy for you because
I think you're gonna be able
to check every box.
You're gonna be able to
help the family business,
help yourself make some money,
but you still have a 100
fucking hours in a week
to fucking sleep, spend time with friends
and do your side hustle.
You're fortunate.
- Now here's, here's what I don't want.
And it's like right now I feel good
and I have that drive
but what do I do tomorrow?
I feel that like,
like man that was great
with Gary yesterday,
and now we're back to
it and it's like cool.
And then the next week it
slowly progress is down.
- Right now tomorrow you go hard,
but then in two weeks you're back to
that place with two
hours into the day of--
- Exactly.
- Like, fuck, I wish it.
so listen, this is what being a man,
and this is what being an
operator in life is about.
Learning how to get comfortable
with the uncomfortable is,
(software interferes with speech)
you know what I mean brother?
- Yeah, learning to get comfortable
with the uncomfortable you said.
- Right.
Learning to like wander in that zone
at 11:00 AM in, on July
19th when you're like,
" fuck man, I wish I was
home playing drums" or
"I wish was, I was with
my boy Salvador right now"
Learning to get over that
hump is very required.
Like that is,
people are, you know,
we are so lucky.
We're so lucky that a lot
of people don't wanna get
a relationship with being uncomfortable.
They just want everything
to be an awesome.
like, it's such macro
entitlement as if everyone's life
should always be awesome at all times.
I don't think this is, you know,
don't create this narrative in
your mind of blaming your mom
that everything has to be
happy is why you're incapable.
That's not your mom
trying to make positives
out of negatives
that's you are fucking so lucky
that you had such great parents
that provided for, that
you are not in a place yet
where you're,
like, you're starting
this incredible process
of getting out of the
entitlement and I'm proud of you.
So now what you need to do,
it's kinda like working out.
It's like kind of that extra
10 pounds on the weight.
Like this summer--
- Get those reps
- Get those reps.
That's exactly right man.
I love that you.
- 100% bro.
- Like every time you're
at 11:30 in the morning
and somebody yells at you at the job
and you're like,
"Fuck man, I could just
be home playing Xbox".
Every time you do that, you go into,
"My fucking parents immigrated to America.
"When they were my age, they
were fucking scared Shitless
"of making it in America.
"They didn't have a
fucking pot to piss in.
"And I'm sitting here complaining about
"a fucking family business
that my dad created
" on his fucking back, that I..."
Go to gratitude.
- (sighs) Man, I just gotta train it man.
Because the main thing
that was confusing me
is I was like, I don't know,
cause you talked about, you know,
if you don't like going or whatever,
then you shouldn't be doing it.
But the thing was that I was doing it.
I was liking it sometimes.
But not like in other
times so then I was like,
what's the deal here?
But you just, man, you just
hit with the your own mind.
Its so real.
- Because what's funny about them as hell,
It's like look,
unhappiness is not
something people should do.
But to your point,
and this is why I love doing Q and A,
when I say don't do something
that you don't love,
I don't mean don't do something
you don't love for an hour.
I mean, don't let that
be your 80 year career.
- Yeah, that's real.
- To me I also say eat shit
and like I believe in eating shit.
Like we just talked
about it in detail here.
11:30 July 19th you know
Miguel on the job yells at you
and says,
"Huh kid, you fucking idiot".
You're like, "Oh fuck".
You know like, you know.
That's the moment you take a step back
and you think about this
conversation and you're like,
"Right when my dad was my age..."
When your dad was 18,
you're 18 or 17?
- I'm 18.
- When your dad was 18 tell
me exactly what he was doing,
if you know.
- he was hustling,
he was installing like video
game machines in Mexican,
whats it called,
- Not really bars, but more than just like
kinda convenience stores.
He would go into, I'll tell
you a story real quick.
He would go into the
store and tell the owners,
he would be like,
"Hey, you mind if I all
these things for you here?"
and they're like,
"No I don't want any
little toys or anything"
And then he'd be like,
" yeah, let me leave them here for a day
and then I'll come back
tomorrow and pick them up
and if you don't still don't want them..."
you know.
And then basically he
will leave him there.
A bunch of kids would come play on them
and buy stuff from the store
and then the store owners would be like,
- Oh shit.
- Yeah, okay, I want 'em.
- Bro, your dad was grinding.
Or your dad didn't love
installing fucking video games
and fucking cranes and
fucking pillars, you know.
But like bro, you have your
whole life in front of you.
You absolutely need to
build a relationship.
Almost everybody under 30 in America,
almost everybody needs
to find a relationship
with adversity and getting
comfortable with eating shit.
And I think its gonna be a great summer
for you to like learn that.
And bro that 40 thing is huge to me.
(mutters)
Bro, I think I can't explain to you
how lucky I think you are.
40?
You have the whole
fucking rest of the week.
- 100%.
- If it's really 40 is
it gonna be really 40,
which is great.
- He said 40 to 50.
If you wanted to, you
know what I'm saying?
- Bro listen man, let
me tell you something.
I thought I was the hardest
working person I knew
when I was 28 years old
running Wine Library.
I fucking worked all day, you know,
8:00 AM to fucking 8:00 PM every day.
That was soft compared
to who I am now at 44.
I go harder, stronger, smarter.
This is about fucking reps
and gaining muscles, right?
You got your stocky dude,
I'm looking at you right now.
You know that if you worked out
like a fucking maniac for a year,
eight bright fucking lifted weights,
you'd be a fucking monster
'cause you've got that build.
That's what I had mentally,
I had that fucking built mentally,
but it was the fucking
reps from doing that
that made me fucking
completely unstoppable.
Look at this like you're
going into training.
You're going into training 40 hours a day
to fucking put callouses
on your fucking hands.
Put fucking quick thickness to your skin,
to your fucking dome.
You're creating do you understand.
This is you going to training.
(software interferes with speech)
You need to be like
Rocky and fucking Rocky.
This is about going in the snow.
Like go into this like,
"Holy shit, I'm so lucky that
I get to go into training.
"I'm gonna get paid to fucking train
"how to be a fucking mental assassin
"for the rest of my life".
You're lucky.
- Yeah.
That's so real bro.
- Yeah bro, and you get
to do it with your dad.
You know how fucking,
you're so fucking lucky.
Most people that are watching right now,
have to do it for boss they don't know.
The greatest thing that ever
happened to me is the memories
of being in the fucking
ranches with my dad,
You know, like,
you know, it's crazy that I
get to have those memories.
One day my dad's gonna be gone
and I'm gonna be so happy
about those hours I put in,
those war stories, you understand?
- Yeah, and I'm crying because I'm happy.
'cause I was on offence
and I didn't wanna leave
cause I liked the electrical
but I didn't wanna leave
to try to get a job
in drumming, right?
Because I was like
I like both I like working with my dad
and so this was really the on mark for me.
And that's why I'm feeling it, man.
- 40 hours a week you can start
a drumming YouTube channel,
you could fucking work at a drumming,
you could work at a
drumming company at night.
You got 40 hours of gigs,.
- Yeah it could be at gigs.
- You have so much time and
you're gonna gain a strength.
You're gonna gain a strength.
- Yeah man, that's so real of like
just being good at being
uncomfortable and being like,
"Hey, this is kinda boring,
but I'm gonna get through it".
Because you know, my family
built this and you know,
I'm so grateful for the
opportunity to even have that
because a lot of people my
age coming out of high school,
they don't know what they wanna do,
don't have a job..."
- Right, and you're gonna learn a skill,
you're gonna learn how to
interact with grown ass men,
interact with customers
that are upset.
You're gonna watch your
dad go through adversity,
you're gonna learn.
you're getting an education
and you're getting a training
and you're gonna get paid,
you should be paying your dad.
- Yeah, I'd appreciate.
(software interferes with speech)
- So grateful that I
decided that when I was,
I realized that 22 that I had it
and I decided instead
of going and building
something for myself cause I could,
I knew the internet, I knew the fucking,
I knew the hustle.
I fucking knew it.
I was making $500 to $1000 when I was 13.
I was 22 I was a grown ass man.
I didn't need to go into
my dad's business for me,
I needed to go into my dad's
business for me emotionally
'cause I wanted to give
back 'cause I knew I could
and I knew I was gona
learn a lot of stuff.
No, did it feel great to
not have a lot of money?
Because in a family business
you really never pay yourself that much.
You know, if I was an executive,
I took the the business from 360 million,
I would have been paid a million a year.
But no.
But those memories with my
dad and doing something,
giving back to my parents,
who came to this country with nothing
and built a foundation that I stand on,
that's something I'll never regret
and you're gonna have that opportunity.
And if I fucking did
only did 40 hours a week,
I would probably start a
baseball card, starting lineups,
eBay flipping business on the side too
and gotten doubled, you know, like happy.
So like, you really have it good, bro.
- And it's so crazy that you say that
because of the fact that like
literally only like a week and a half ago,
I told my mom and I just
talked with her and I was like,
"Man, I'm so grateful for you guys"
'cause I just felt this
gratitude wave of like,
"Man, I'm so grateful",
but I just didn't know how
to apply it to the work day
because I was confused on
like, whether or not, you know.
but man.
'cause it's all about
the perspective of like,
when I'm older, I'm gonna be
able to look back and say,
"I got to work with my dad.
" got to do the 40 hours, like you said,
"and I can still do my other stuff"
And you know.
- Let me, Misael you can
go 80 hours for seven years
and fucking be 25 and young as fuck.
I'd break both my arms
off right now to be 25.
you can go just 90 hours a week,
do no drums and bounce out
of there as a fucking child.
Still a child.
You have everything.
you have gratitude and
perspective and maturity at 18
and you have your whole
life in front of you.
You've got 100 more years of life.
You're gonna live for a
hundred more years, bro
on so little shit.
You're a part of that lucky generation.
You're gonna live to
one 118, motherfucker.
- I believe that.
I can see that.
I could see it, at least 100.
- 118.
You're gonna live 100 more.
Listen to me, you will
never, ever, ever regret
working 40 to 50 hours
a week with your dad
for a long period of time.
I promise you that .
I'm rarely that definitive,
but I've spent enough
time with you right now
to know that to be true.
You've got too much of
that soul and gratitude
towards your parents.
Any kid who's watching
right now who is grateful
and loves their parents
for what they did for them
should go into the family business.
Because even if it's a disaster,
you'll always be happy that
you paid back a little bit
to the thing that put you on.
- Yeah, that's so real.
Can we take a photo real quick?
- Yes dear.
- Right, are you ready?
I don't know what I'm doing here.
I'll just doing a little peace sign.
Maybe a little little rock on
- We are the fucking drummer.
All right brother.
- Hey, have a good one.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
How was that like?
Like that, Dustin?
- Robert.
- Dustin, you're fucking on my flow.
Yeah (laughs)
that's a good one.
When I think of my pops I
get a little teary eyed.
Lets go to Robert.
Robert?
- Hey, what's going on
Gary, how are things?
- Things are amazing
my friend, how are you?
- I'm doing well.
As well as one can be.
Sorry, can you see me right now?
I can't even tell, its all black.
- It's awesome from here I see everything.
- Okay, dope.
Yeah, my name is Robert.
A lot of people know me as Bobby T.
I'm from Edmonton, Alberta in Canada.
You were supposed to come to
the city I think in two days,
but obviously because of
the current landscape,
you're not gonna make it.
- Good news.
I'm working with the organizers.
It looks like we're going to be able to
get an up there in September.
- Okay, dope.
That's super dope.
So a little bit context about myself.
I have like my own
marketing agency here called
Bridge Me media where we specialize
mainly in content production
but then also community management
and those kind of like different lanes.
And obviously the one question
I kind of had for you,
I actually have two questions.
The first question I
have have of you is like,
in this clearly current
landscape of things
I know there's like a ton,
like we've lost a ton of business
just due to people now holding tight.
But then also we're holding
onto a couple clients
who right now are in different industries
that are just now working
very strong to kind of engage
their current customers
and as like a B to B.
And my question to you is for right now,
for people who are having
sort of smaller agencies,
what would you recommend
our strategy should be
in terms of like trying
to grow or navigate
or still just hold on tight here.
And so yeah, what would you,
what are your thoughts around that?
- Two things.
One, I would go heavy into sales mode
and heavy into content mode.
I would probably do a lot of LinkedIn
and a lot of Twitter searching
and a lot of cold out reach out
and think about companies that are busy,
restaurants that might be
doing delivery, food services
because when you're a small
business you need cash
and when you lose clients,
you know, it can get ugly real quick
as I'm sure you know Bobby.
So one if I'm you,
so is it your company?
- Yes my company.
- You have employees
or is it all free roam?
- It's free, I have
freelancers that work with me,
so I have a few that basically
have like a video team.
I have like a writers, I
have like graphic designers
who are all local and this all
works for me to pay on items.
- You don't have overhead
'cause you don't have a payroll right?
- No.
- Beautiful.
so you know, honestly
then specifically for you,
sales is important but not required
because for example, for me,
I have a thousand people on payroll.
Like that scary shit as
we lose clients, you know?
So for me one of the things to do now
is to really go on the offense on content.
If you've got downtime, this
is the time for you to make
500 fucking videos of, you know,
I'm a big fan of what if.
like I think one of the
biggest mistakes small,
Agencies make is they think
that information they have
is what they sell and I
think it's the execution.
So one of the reasons I
put out all my best advice
is I don't mind if a Bobby T in Edmonton
picks up on that free information
and go get some business.
That makes me happy for karma
and two, I don't think people
sign with us for my smarts
even though I'm a progressive
forward mover, thought leader.
I think it's about the execution.
So I think right now I would probably,
let me just make role play,
I'm probably making 500 YouTube videos
'cause I think that
archives and it's search
of Bobby T's what ifs.
What if I was a car dealership in Edmonton
during the Coronavirus
and post Coronavirus
and then just make a video.
I'd be like, I would set up this,
I would do this, I would
start my Instagram.
I would make--
Like, I would literally do that
for like 500 different business sectors.
- Okay, that makes sense.
- This is the time for
you to go ham on yourself
and everybody overthinks fucking quality.
Look at how I'm doing this right now,
I've got the window behind me
(software interferes with speech)
- Donut overthink shit, Bobby T.
They're like,
"Oh, that doesn't look professional".
Fuck that, It's the words of your mouth.
- No, 100%.
And I, and I know your
quality over quantity
kind of mindset and I
totally understand that
and I'm blessed and I'm lucky that I have
a really dope studio that
I can just quickly bang out
some of these items and stuff
that I've been building.
So, really appreciate that word of advice.
- People think about YouTube
in subscribers and views,
I think about YouTube
like a search engine.
I think you should put out
500 fucking videos on YouTube
that literally have the
word "Edmonton" in the title
because they will become fucking King
of the SMB in that area.
Or if you wanna make it alberta,
if you wanna make it or Canada,
or America or the world.
Like you decide you but think about...
This is actually great general advice.
Think about YouTube like a search engine.
Not like Netflix where you're
looking for views and ratings.
Everybody doesn't make content
because they're trying
to make fucking, you know
they're trying to make
videos and get tons of views
and get subscribers and
my whole thing is like,
no.
Make videos as a search engine so that
a hairstylist in Edmonton
stumbles on your video
and what marketing you would
do if you were a hairstylist,
which then leads for them to
reach out to you and be like,
"Yo, I'm a hairstylist at Edmonton.
"I'd like to pay you 1500 a
month to fucking do this for me.
Everyone's stuck at home.
Make content.
You have a studio, are
you fucking kidding me?
Make 500 to 1000 videos where the title
is a search engine query.
Listen for your business
you're getting 187
187 views on what I would do
if I was a butcher in Alberta
For my business, you're
getting 187 views on that
leads to two butchers and you $800 a month
for you to be their agency.
- 100%.
That makes total sense.
And I have a, my second
question I just had
is actually, it's about my wife.
So my wife, she's an awesome music artist.
She does kids music, she
is such a great performer
and we're trying to figure out also
like sort of, what would be
like sort of a solid strategy
for her to grow her brand
and then in the game of
yes, content, content, content
and jumping on the platforms
and pushing on the content.
What we're trying to figure out is like,
and you kind of were
speaking to this early
when you were making a reference point
about how for that individual
who's writing books,
I'm teaming up with different
artists to kind of create
contextual content for like Tik Tok
or contextual content in Instagram
and writing blurbs to get people to share.
And I'm wondering what
are your thoughts around
people who are in the music area
and specifically around kids music,
what should they be doing
and how can they do stuff
other than just making
I guess music videos.
Is there other layers
that we can kind of go
to create or grow her brand?
- I think Tik Tok is incredibly important.
If I'm her, she's putting
out four Tik Toks a day.
- Four Tik Toks a day.
'cause Tik Tok is so viral.
Did you see the ant farm
guy a couple of hours ago?
- Yes, yes.
- I mean for her it's Tik Tok.
I think Facebook because
you're gonna get to moms
on Facebook and Instagram.
You know a Facebook group, I think.
Well let me throw this one at you.
I think becoming the
moderator of a Facebook group
that is narrow but has,
you know, as you can imagine for her,
(mutters)
- Is a goal of her getting
booked by parents to do events?
- Yeah, books at institutions
in terms of like local libraries,
doing little singalongs for
kids and things like that.
- Facebook group right now would be huge.
I also think live streaming right now
'cause parents are
fucking besides themselves
having their kids in their home 24/7.
They're looking for
ways to entertain kids.
This is a viral moment opportunity for her
where she just goes live and entertains
and like starts a Facebook group for moms
where moms know that they
can just put their kid
in front of a laptop with
her from 11 to one every day.
No different than what I did
from nine to 11 right now.
So like I think Facebook group
where she's the moderator
around kids activities,
which then leads to people booking her
as long as she's not
trying to sell herself
in the group at every
minute, but providing value.
But I think live streams
and I think do ticktocks.
Four Tik Toks a day,
I mean it.
- Four Tik Toks a day.
(software interferes with speech)
- And then making kid video
versions of that will crush.
Everybody.
The amount of 13 year olds on TiK Tok
that have six year old
siblings is remarkable.
- Okay so then by engaging those teenagers
who will then engage their
younger brothers or sisters,
they'll just go full loop
while they'll be giving
the phones to these.
Thanks, I've never even
thought about like that.
- No, that is --
- Do you see where I'm going?
I'm 13 years old Sarah.
"Hey Tiffany, come here,
you've gotta watch this.
"This looks like right for you".
You know, got it?
- Yeah.
That's huge.
(software interferes with speech)
- You know, that's how it works.
- No, it's wicked.
I appreciate,
I appreciate all that.
And then I haven't asked for you Gary.
So, when you said that
you're coming to Edmonton,
I have my own podcast show.
It's called 360 chat
with just with Bobby T.
And it'd be awesome.
I would love to interview you
when you come down Edmonton.
- So Bobby here, I'm going
to make a 90% promise
cause I don't know about logistics.
I might just fly in and out.
But a 90% promise.
Email me right now, gary@vaynermedia.
Say it's Bobby from Edmonton
and I'll probably give you
10 minutes in the green room
before I go on stage
for a quick little take.
- Wicked though.
I appreciate that so much.
- Talk to you soon.
(software interferes with speech)
called with vayner media.
Thank you for everybody
who spent two hours with me this morning.
I'm gonna try with you a bunch of these
this week, next week.
And then the more Corona,
the more Tea time with Gary.
So Dustin, thank you.
The rest of the team, thank you.
Anybody who watched this
morning I wish you guys
nothing but the best much love.
See you.